hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology I see there are a bunch
of interesting questions here gosh where
to start
uh
commented question from Matt who says
what's the history behind emails and
instant messaging they say I have a hard
time imagining life before then and
handling communication that may not get
a response for days waiting for a letter
in the mail okay so I'm an old guy so I
existed long before uh
well for a fair time before
um email and so on let me make a few
comments
first of all
the Postal Service in many places was
really surprisingly efficient for
example I was studying the history of
Ada Lovelace and Charles Babbage who
were active in the 1830s 1840s they both
lived in London
they lived on a mile and a half apart or
something and at that time in London
there were 14 mail deliveries per day
and so you see in the archives of uh Ada
and babbage's stuff you see
um actual letters exchanged multiple per
day
very much like email so this idea that
that things were sort of slow
communication was slow
is really not true for the time of uh
you know I don't know how many mail
deliveries there are in Central London
today I bet it's a lot less than 14 but
back in those days there were lots of
mail deliveries I'm sure that what's
determined mail deliveries is part it's
the cost of Labor and things like that
maybe one that if you know there are
robotic mail deliveries it'll be up to
lots of physical deliveries per day
um I'm not sure what uh I don't think
we're quite there yet in terms of those
little troubling robots that you see in
in some places these days
um
I think and and uh we're not there in
terms of what people thought maybe five
years ago that there'd be in a flying
drone deliveries all over the place that
that has not come to pass as of yet
um I the I mean the kind of the uh yeah
the the the the kind of image of of
things that could go wrong there is is
uh can get quite um quite diverse
but in terms of of um
electronic communications
um the you know the thing that really
opened all that up was the telegraph
which was I think
1830s maybe Samuel Mawson people like
that inventing Morse code and people
wiring up
um
uh
Telegraph lines all over the place I
mean I should say by the way in terms of
of mail delivery
um I don't know what the sort of peak
mail delivery in um in the US has ever
been I'm sure New York City will have
been the place where there would have
been the most of it
um there were lots of things in
infrastructure in New York City for
example that uh have kind of mostly gone
away but were allowed for pretty rapid
communication for example in tall
buildings the idea of pneumatic tubes
that would go from floor to floor where
you would put your um your message in a
tube and you would you would specify
where that how that tube was going to be
routed through the building and then
somebody would pick up the tube at the
other end I mean I remember years ago
um that uh uh
when FedEx was a was a young company in
the 1980s
um the uh
um
uh
um having
kind of uh realizing that what was
sending a FedEx from a company that was
on one floor of a building in New York
City to another floor the building in
New York City but FedEx was routing all
of its traffic through its hub in
Memphis Tennessee and so that that
letter was almost certainly going from
one floor of the building to Memphis
Tennessee and back to another floor of
that building
so you know these Technologies do tend
to sort of uh circulate around
um and I think uh uh but you know
pneumatic tubes was an interesting
technology but back to the electronic
side of it you know the telegraph was
sort of the earliest uh story of um of
kind of um
um
uh of of a way to communicate
um electronically across you know across
large distances and uh you know it
became sort of a premium thing to be a
very fast clicker of the um of the
telegraph key and so on
um and the telegraph operator
in terms of people's sort of General
communication uh you know letters
obviously in a country like the US it's
pretty big
um there are plenty of letters were
quite slow and you know there were
exotic things like the Pony Express you
know writing from one side of the
country to another and so on I mean
another thing to realize about letter
mail when I was a kid
um you know airmail was a a non-trivial
concept you know you would send a letter
by airmail and you would typically have
these little blue uh kind of um envelope
things that folded up that were
incredibly thin paper so that the um you
know the airmail letter was very light
so that you could um and and I think you
know when the first um uh mail services
by plane came into existence shortly
after the the development of planes
um the uh you know people would pack
lots and lots of these airmail letters
that had to be really light to be able
to um to you know to go from here to
there I I seem to remember at least in
England the ml letters
um had sort of you would buy a form
letter thing that would fold up and it
would have its stamp already on it and
um that was so its stamp was sort of
built into the the ml construct and that
would be the thing that was used to pay
for it now you know at some point in the
in the exchange of letters there's this
non-trivial thing that there are you
know a couple of hundred countries in
the world and how a letter goes from one
country to another and so on is not such
a trivial thing because you have to have
what is at the international Postal
Union or something has to make deals
with oh you you know somebody bought the
stamp in country one but it's going to
be the letter is going to be delivered
in country two how does that work how do
you kind of clear the um the sort of the
expense because maybe more many more
people are writing you know from the US
to Country X that are writing from
country x to the US those kinds of
things
in any case back to sort of the origins
of things like email so there were there
were telegrams which were sort of
standardized places to send uh Telegraph
messages for you know you could have a
telegraph message that was sent
um
uh uh by um
uh I guess was sent from one sort of
company or or to another you know
particularly in the case of financial
kinds of transactions things like this
but then there was kind of the consumer
end of it which was in the US Western
Union I guess was the the organization
that did most of that where you would
just show up at a Western Union sort of
place and say I want to send a telegram
to somebody else and then uh you know
that would be that would be sent by
Telegraph and then uh this printed out
at the other end and uh you know I think
telegrams when did they stop being a
thing I sent a telegram
in 1980
or 3 1983 but they were definitely by
that time kind of really making a point
exotic uh kinds of communications they
had definitely gone gone out of
circulation now one thing that came in
and I'm I'm kind of giving the sister in
slightly peculiar order but one thing
that came in was the fax machine so you
know the concept of taking a telegram a
telegraph
and using it to transmit kind of digital
image data that You Could reconstruct as
an image was a a concept that existed
even in the early 1800s I mean I think
famously I think Gauss who did a bunch
of astronomy work had you know an
observatory at the top of a mountain and
you know his office down at the bottom
of the mountain and things and I think
had some early kind of Proto fax machine
based on on the telegraph but the actual
concept of the fax machine and its sort
of electronic implementation didn't come
in until uh the early 80s
um and actually part of what I think
enabled that was compression technology
because you know most of a piece of
paper that you might transmit is blank
and so you typically it's using run
length encoding where you're just saying
there are lots of pixels and there are a
thousand identical pixels so just say
there's it's this pixel color and copy
it a thousand times
and that was the sort of compression
technique used for typical faxes
but faxes came in uh I think when was it
early 1980s
um they were sort of started arriving
and it was it was an interesting
economic moment because I remember that
FedEx for example in its early days had
a thing I think was called zap mail
which was a same day few hour delivery
service and it worked by you have a
message it would then get faxed to the
destination which was another FedEx
Office and then they would dispatch
somebody to go deliver the the print out
of that message
it was interesting that that service
lasted only a very short time because
the cost curves for fax machines were
being driven at such a rate that it
quickly became possible for for sort of
individual people to have fax machines
and and that happened when did that
happen that was like
um
mid-1980s it became common to have a fax
machine and to have and and I certainly
remember when we started Walton research
in 1986 it was absolutely uh you know
there was a fact we still have the same
fax number I'm sure if you send a fax
number you know uh to um uh uh the the
there's there's a fax number which I'm
sure has been the same since 1986 for
some research and I I don't know quite
what happens to a facts that's sent
there anymore I'm sure it's transmitted
electronically uh you know by by
computer at this point to something
um but that was that was another kind of
form of um of fast messaging was was the
fax machine idea another thing that had
been an earlier idea that existed from
the 1930s I think maybe 40s was the
Telex machine Telex machine was kind of
a uh
a well let's see that was a kind of a
merger of phone technology and a sort of
telegraph transmission of
um
um of of of kind of written material and
so Telex machine you would typically you
would dial a number
but then you would have a piece of paper
tape it was five hole paper tape usually
you would have pre-typed your message
because you didn't want to be on the
phone very long because you were often
sending it to another part of the world
um you would uh have have typed your
message so that it was recorded on the
paper tape then as soon as the Telex
connects you would start off the paper
tape going through and it would send
that those that Digital Data through to
the other end and then at the other end
the Telex machine will print out the
message and that was another kind of
fast way of communicating before there
was email
well the first email that I used was
actually on an MIT the mitmc computer
MIT multiple access uh computer
um which was a node of the Opera net
um at that time the up and that had 512
nodes I think this was around 1986.
and um at that time you could log in you
could create an account on this kind of
Public Access computer and when you
created an account you had to have a
username and
um uh once you had that username people
on that computer could send you messages
under that username and so that was a
that was a thing I was very sad that my
um the obvious SW username for me was
taken when I first logged into that um
computer in 1986 from from England or
whatever over the Opera net
um and so I I picked swole Fest wlf
which was for a long time my my login
um and uh I many many years later I met
the person who had the SW for that
machine but um in any case the um
uh uh but but on that machine local to
that machine you could get messages and
you know I still have messages that were
sort of email messages that were sent
locally to that machine
when things jumped sort of to other
machines the primary place I saw that
was in this thing called uucp the Unix
to Unix copy system and what would
happen there was that there was a place
where there was email but you would
typically give your like for example I
was at the institute for advanced study
and it had
um a uh maybe I even set this up I'm not
even sure
um you would you would want to at that
time this is early 1980s you would be
wanting to send a message to somebody
and the address would look like machine
name exclam machine name exclam machine
name and so on because what was
happening was that one machine was
calling on the phone another machine
using a modem and you know communicating
through a modem then it was calling
another machine it was kind of a routing
of a message from through quotes email
but but you were explicitly saying you
go from this machine to this machine to
this machine to get to where you want to
go to now there were a few competing
networks there was a thing called bitnet
which I think IBM put up that was for
universities uh then there was some uh
and and that was another thing that had
where people would have bitnat addresses
and they would have uucp addresses and
so on I remember when I started the
complex systems journal in 1986 we had
all sorts of exotic uh sort of email
like addresses that could be used to
submit papers electronically it was the
the very first Journal that could take
um electronic submissions of papers back
in 1986 I I have to say I was a little
bit embarrassed you know 20 years later
when I realized we hadn't actually
updated the instructions to contributors
in 20 years and we were still talking
about bitnat and floppy disks and things
like this but that was a um uh that was
kind of the the early days of that now
now then
in uh uh by the time I started our
company in 1986
um there were things were becoming a bit
more standardized and you could you know
buy blocks of IP addresses
um we had 140.177
um was our class B address block that we
that we bought back in 1986
um and uh eventually became quite
valuable we actually sold part of it
recently
um at uh
because we didn't need uh that whole
collection of addresses and uh there's a
there's a real
um uh death of of um ipv4 addresses at
the present time
um so but uh that was a thing by 1986
people were sort of more routinely
um uh using email I remember actually
um just to give a sense of sort of the
the arrival of email
um
the
even by the 1993 I remember actually
going the one time I went to the world
economic Forum
um uh meeting
um talking to all kinds of people there
who were sort of thinking about the
world in the future and all that kind of
thing and telling them you should really
pay attention to the the internet and um
you know an email and so on and there's
still that wasn't wasn't yet a thing by
1993 but that was it was just so that
people had heard of it but it wasn't yet
kind of a thing so but there was so you
know this idea of kind of uh you know
everybody could connect to the internet
and um use email was was something that
sort of uh I I suppose a a mid-90s kind
of thing now meanwhile there had been
copies of and AOL and so on and Company
serve must have existed in
ah let's see that must have existed in
the early 1980s because I remember
meeting
one of the people who had been a founder
of that or who had been sort of rejected
from it actually uh meeting them around
1983 and that it was already past
history so that had existed as a thing
that you dialed into using I guess the
very first generation of personal
computers so I suppose there were there
were these different kinds of networks
there were ones that you could connect
to with you know a personal computer and
then it was all sort of server-based and
there are ones where you actually had
your computer do things like call
another computer that was typically done
by things like mini computers uh by mini
computer I mean these computers that was
size of a you know large desks and
things things like the vax uh uh
computer they were called mini computers
because they were much smaller than
mainframe computers
so there's a bit of a disorganized um
um uh response here about about
um messaging I mean I suppose that um uh
what is curious is that a lot of the uh
the the kind of the mechanisms of SMS
for instant messaging and so on you know
a lot of that kind of the the at least
the conventions for how that worked sort
of were a bit derived from the way that
people used to write telegrams and so on
um and uh uh you know I think even the
original Twitter 140 character limit was
derived from sort of a telegram
um type uh uh uh convention
um but uh
uh yeah so I mean I I think by
when I mean
by some time
in the early 90s by mid 90s probably it
was
uh I mean there was a time when it was
very exotic to have an email address
and that became sort of progressively
letter less exotic and there were times
when people had uh when there were very
disjoint networks of you know oh I can
you know I can get onto bit net so I can
contact you and things
um and then it all sort of became the
the sort of the global email
um uh Network
um complete with all of its uh strange
protocols like the SMTP protocol
um what's that simple mail transfer
protocol which is the the main one
that's used between mail servers that
has this charming uh thing where the
mail servers connect and they they send
one of them says to the other in you
know is its connection message something
like pleased to meet you
um and that's being transmitted you know
billions of times a day around the world
um but that's uh yeah that's a little
bit of a sketch of some of that history
um sorry that was a little bit um
uh
disorganized them I apologies
um just remembering all sorts of
different things
uh the question here from many asking
what were the early days of alpha like
well let's see
you know when I was a kid I was
interested in kind of collecting
information and I was sort of uh
thinking about computers and things and
I was like I want to collect all this
information and somehow organize it to
be useful I didn't really get the idea
of having One automatically be able to
retrieve the information by computer but
by about 19 when I started developing
SMP which was a forerunner of awesome
language I started developing that in
1979 and I kind of had this idea of
encoding things like mathematical
knowledge in uh this computational
system and I was interested in coding
other kinds of knowledge and the
computational system as well and I had
thought at the time that the only way
that you would be able to like answer
questions about the world would be to
have sort of a brain like AI doing it
and so I was interested this is my 1980
or so I got interested in well how would
you make a brain like Ai and I was
interested in things like neural Nets
and figuring out you know how would you
make sort of uh in in the language that
I built with SMP which is now sort of in
a much evolved form in woven language
one of the key ideas is this notion of
Transformations for symbolic Expressions
you have a symbolic expression that
represents something like a mathematical
formula and you then make
Transformations for that and the way the
Transmissions are specified is by giving
patterns which are more from language or
blanks underscores that are sort of the
key elements of patterns and you might
say you know f of x underscore comma
underscore colon equals whatever and
that says you know Transformer anything
F of something which is named X and
anything else transform that in this way
so that was a notion of kind of patterns
that were very precisely specified
um for patterns for symbolic Expressions
where you're saying this subtree of the
symbolic expression can be anything you
want a little bit like a generalization
to trees of regular expressions for
Strings where you can say this can be
any sequence of characters and so on but
that was the kind of my idea for
patterns which has been an idea that's
been a pretty good idea it's you know
we're at uh you know 40 40 something
years and counting and that idea is a
very powerful idea that has been a
foundation for pretty much the whole
structure of the symbolic language that
we built in uh in SNP in a more from
language now
so very very powerful idea but back in
1980 or so I was interested in sort of
fuzzifying that kind of pattern matching
and making it so that one could for
example do things like say there are
these words and they kind of mean the
same thing as these other words and they
both kind of match the same pattern and
that got me into thinking a lot about
neural Nets and I certainly understood
the idea of attractors where you're
saying there's a whole bunch of images
and they all correspond to this one
thing that's either a cat or a dog and
this idea that you would evolve from the
initial sort of presented image down to
the sort of canonical uh sort of cat
point or the canonical dog point I
didn't understand that
um I I worked a bit on neural Nets but I
never managed to make them do anything
interesting the neural Nets I was
dealing with were really tiny and and
much more precisely trained and not as
sort of heuristically and and
iteratively trained as modern deep
learning neural Nets have been but so
that was kind of my my first idea was if
you want to make a general question
answering General know about the world
kind of system you're going to have to
make it brain like and so I tried to
figure out how to make a brain like AI
type thing and that turned out to be
pretty hard
so I I kind of returned to that question
a bunch of times but then in the 1990s
when I was working on my big book A New
Kind of Science one of the things that
came out there was this thing called the
principle of computational equivalence
which was this idea that if you look at
different kinds of computational systems
with different kinds of rules that above
some extremely low threshold all these
different kinds of systems are
ultimately equivalent in their
computational capabilities and so one of
the implications of that was the idea
that there's no sort of bright line
between the intelligent and the merely
computational
and so back
um
in uh
uh back in um
uh in 2002 when I finished that book I
kind of you know as I was sort of
thinking about things I kind of no
longer had the excuse that oh we're
gonna have to invent this brain like AI
if we were going to do this
computational knowledge thing it had the
potential to be sort of a a pure play
computational idea so that was something
that I sort of was starting to think
about again
um after
the book came out and I sort of
recovered from the uh well the 10 years
that I spent working on the book and the
couple of years that I spent kind of
telling the world about that book and
actually
um
uh one of my kids who must have been at
that point who
six seven years old something like that
uh now a very uh computationally
sophisticated individual but at the time
it was just starting to learn kind of
Orphan language stuff and was saying why
can't I just type
serve things in in pure plain English
and it's like I'm like well because it's
really hard to make that work and he's
like but look there are only a limited
number of ways you can say this I don't
completely believe that but maybe so
that was another kind of impetus to
think about kind of is there a way to
take kind of uh uh something like wolf
language or then in Mathematica
um and uh uh and sort of represent that
you know access that using using plain
language
and so between these different pieces we
kind of started in maybe 2004 uh
to sort of explore what would it take to
have a essentially document
documentationless access
to uh being able to computationally
answer questions by documentationless I
mean you just type what you think you
should type nobody has to tell you a
structured way to type it
and and that kind of sort of merged with
the thing that I'd long been also
interested in of sort of taking in
Wilson language and we had a certain
amount of sort of we obviously had a lot
of mathematical and algorithmic
knowledge of you know here's how to do
all these kinds of integrals here's how
this works here's how that works and we
had a limited amount of kind of just
structural fact fact type knowledge
um but I kind of got interested in could
we make uh sort of a more systematic
effort of uh sort of representing
systematic knowledge in the world and
one of the questions was how much
systematic knowledge is there in the
world can you organize it collect it Etc
et cetera Etc and at first it seemed
quite daunting but I was you know I had
been a serious user of reference
knowledge for you know practically my
whole life and so I had some idea of
what sort of what existed out there you
know when you wanted to find reference
and information about this or that what
would you find out there and actually
back in must have been I don't know 2005
2006
um I remember taking the team that we'd
assembled to start working on what would
become of an alpha
um to um
to take that um that team around to kind
of get a a sense of how much we had to
actually encode in the system and so we
went to Big reference library at
University of Illinois actually
um at um uh to um uh to sort of get a
sense of of what is there that needs to
be encoded computationally in a big room
and it kind of looks a bit daunting
because it's full of books but you
realize there's not that many different
things here and I remember that um I was
really pushing for all sorts of
different kinds of material I think we
went to an engineering Library
um and I was saying we really need uh
for example phase diagrams of materials
just one of you know we're making a big
list of different kinds of things we
need and I was like we really need this
look there are all these books about
this stuff and I pull one off the shelf
and a giant cloud of dust sort of
emerges and it's like there was a lot of
dust collected on this book nobody's
looked at this book for many years you
know maybe it's not such an important
priority after all but anyway that that
was some that was kind of that um uh
that side of it then you know in the in
the very early days uh sort of one
branch of this we were going to call it
calculate as because you know we really
were emphasizing doing calculations and
then came in this sort of big idea of
sort of computational knowledge about
the world and entities and symbolic
representation of those kinds of things
actually we released the first versions
of that in Wolf language before before
Wolfman Alpha came out
one of the challenges with both malpha
was until it really worked quite well it
wasn't going to be at all convincing it
wasn't going to be at all clear what you
would do with it because it's like well
it does these questions but it doesn't
do his other questions how do I know
which questions it does sort of the goal
was a documentationalist system where
you just walk up to it and it will
usually be able to do something useful
and I think that was something that
actually I have to say in terms of sort
of management organization that was a a
kind of a tricky thing because we had um
uh you know my management team really
didn't know what the point of this whole
project was and I I have to say I kind
of ended up in this is what you got to
do in in private companies like ours we
I I kind of sort of hid the project for
quite a while
um as uh as something that um uh
wouldn't really engage with people
saying no no there's a waste of time
there's a waste of time I preferred for
people just not to sort of have an
opinion about it until it was ready and
when it was ready and I was able to demo
it people were were within half an hour
pretty excited about it
um and uh uh but that was some uh you
know there was definitely a a something
of a threshold effect of when the thing
was to the point where sort of the
typical question you might ask it would
actually be able to to make an answer to
or not
we really didn't know what people would
ask we didn't know what expectations
people would have about what was
possible how much idea people would have
of what was an askable answerable
question in the modern world I mean I I
could tell many stories about sort of
the Dynamics of introductionable from
alpha
um you know it was it was a big high
wire act in terms of actual server
deployments and um actually setting
things up I one of the things um I'll
tell a couple of stories here
um one was about two or maybe two three
weeks before Wolfman Alpha came out in
in May of of 2009
um I was at some event and I run into uh
marvininski it was somebody I'd known
for many years who was sort of a a
pioneer of of AI kinds of of thinking
and so on and so I I say to Marvin hey
I've we've got this thing and you know
it's sort of an interesting system and
it does question answering and in the
kind of world of artificial intelligence
people have been talking about question
answering for years I remember actually
maybe a year or two before Wolfman came
out I remember going to some event
I think it was at MIT where there was
some group that was doing question
answering and it was like like you know
they had a question answering system
like that's cool and we tried out and
it's like it was absolutely hopeless it
knew nothing I mean it was it was and I
don't I don't actually even know
completely what the point of it was
supposed to be
um but people had sort of had this idea
of doing question answering for a long
time but they just hadn't had you know
they hadn't really been able to make a
system that that reached the threshold
of being useful
and uh in addition people had had sort
of the idea of doing let's understand
natural language with a machine and one
of the key things which I only realized
after the fact that made it possible for
us to do that successfully when it
hadn't been possible before is in the
past people had said let's abstractly
try and understand natural language well
what does that mean you know the
computer puts a light on says I
understand
okay that's hard to to analyze but with
wealth language we had the symbolic
representation of computational ideas
and we have a Target so you know we're
turning English or Spanish or Japanese
or whatever it is into uh that symbolic
language we have a definite Target and
that's why we were able to be successful
at doing natural language understanding
what people hadn't been but back to my
story with with Marvin Minsky so you
know Marvin had seen many attempts at
question answering systems over the
years and uh you know Marvin was always
talking about all kinds of wild things
like I can't remember what the wild
thing that he was talking about before I
was talking about wolf malpho was but um
anyway so I say you know
that um uh it's some uh you know become
this thing and so I said do you want to
try it out so
um uh you know it's like oh okay fine
and whatever and and you know then it's
changing the subject back again and I
said no no you should actually try
typing some things here and so so then
starts off typing things and then
there's this moment where he says oh my
God it actually works
which you know because he'd seen many
question answering systems before that
just had never worked and we finally had
something that actually worked and I
think it was a very it was very
interesting for sort of the Dynamics of
of the AI Community which was at that
time very small the II Community had
really been beaten down by many many
many failures many things that hadn't
worked out
um and I think wolfen Alpha I didn't
really present it terribly much as an AI
thing because people hadn't really paid
it much attention to AI at the time but
it was something that in a sense
provided a success in this general idea
of AI
um in a way that was very different from
the way I'd sort of imagined of you know
make a brain like thing you know Wolfram
Alpha is just an engineering system so
it has a bunch of clever ideas in it but
it is ultimately just an engineering
system that is merely computational and
it does it does those kinds of things I
remember when we were actually going to
launch wolfen Alpha
um one of the big issues was we had no
idea what the traffic would be and so we
had a certain number of servers we had a
uh I think we already had multiple colos
that we'd set up
um with servers on them and um
we just didn't have any idea what the
traffic would be and so I talked to a
couple of of people who had tried to
stand up uh Services
um uh one was kind of a um
uh one was the search engine and one was
a kind of
knowledgey questiony type system and
they both had had other disasters they
they had got their systems up and then
you know they've been announced uh to
the world and people have started using
them and the systems have both fallen
over so I was I was like I need to talk
to the people who did these systems um
one was called cool a one was called
true knowledge and they were very
helpful and you know one of them said
you know our logging system just got
completely backlogged and blew up and
the other one I forget what happened to
them they had some other
some other horror that was unexpected
um based on traffic volume so we were
very aware of this and we didn't know
how much traffic we would expect how
many queries per second to expect
um and we also were um uh we started
doing tests but we also borrowed a sort
of a supercomputer uh worth of of um uh
of of machines as sort of an overflow
for our main
um
uh our main sort of uh uh system
and we also then sort of did this thing
of oh we're going to launch it on a
Friday night but its official launch is
going to be Monday morning and we're
going to get sort of a pre-launch on the
Friday night when hopefully there won't
be as many people around and we'll get
to see what happens we also decided that
um uh we would um actually no maybe it
was a Saturday we were going to launch
on
um we uh we also decided that
um uh you know what the heck let's make
an event out of the launch and if
something if the whole thing Falls over
and crashes and burns let's at least
make that something that people can kind
of see what happened
so we decided um uh to do to live stream
it and this was a time when um
there was uh live streaming was sort of
a very new thing there was this chap I
uh knew named Justin can who had a thing
called justin.tv which eventually turned
into twitch
um but uh anyway
um contacted Justin and we kind of got
set up to be able to do essentially a
live streamed uh version of the launch
of Orphan Alpha back in 2009
um and uh so we um that was sort of the
the thing where
where we decided we among other things
that sort of stimulated us to build out
this uh nice kind of Mission Control
setup with lots of good monitoring and
so on and actually I have to say we we
used a lot of that monitoring for uh we
I think we still used some of that
monitoring even today and the effort to
build it out so that it was sort of good
and made for TV so to speak turned out
to be a really good idea just in terms
of our internal use of those monitoring
Technologies and so on but any case we
we uh we then got to the point where we
could actually launch the launch the
thing it had many disasters right up to
the very last minute
um you know I I kind of thought it was
all going to be plain sailing and it's
just like press a button and we're live
and it's all good and we see the traffic
coming in and we we see what happens uh
one of the more exotic things that
happened was that uh the day we're doing
and do this there was uh we you know our
main Colo yeah we had milk we had three
colors I think at that time our main
Colo was in Central Illinois
and uh uh there we are and there's a
tornado watch and so it seems like uh
you know everything may may sort of uh
uh get get destroyed because there's a
tornado heading right for our location
but it it went away it didn't uh was
like an hour before we were due to
launch I think that that happened
um so uh when we actually launched
traffic started coming in we started
seeing queries we started seeing all
kinds of exotic things happening all
kinds of expectations people had mostly
we did okay mostly we we seem to satisfy
expectations although there were some
pretty funny things that happened I mean
one thing that is sort of a memorable
thing was um it was a question of what
would be the you know if something went
wrong uh you know how would we indicate
that and so we had some quickly designed
kind of um uh how uh to from 2001 like I
Type image and we thought just for fun
we would put up something that says you
know I'm sorry I can't do that Dave
which is you know a line from the from
the movie
um uh from from its AI computer so to
speak
um and uh okay this is all fine until
somebody uh is trying to use the system
and it uh and they do something which it
can't do and it comes back with a
message I'm sorry I can't do that Dave
but it so happened that the person who
who uh who asked the question happened
to be called Dave and so they were both
sort of uh uh confused and um uh and
surprised and so on and so we got kind
of an interesting message from them but
that was kind of the very very early uh
moments of of wolfen Alpha and and I
have to say that the people's
expectations about the system were
um
well mostly no not we you know we
managed to communicate I think
reasonably well what the expectations
were the media did not do us a great
favor because they were like oh it's a
search engine it's you know it's a
Google competitor it's whatever now that
may have made more people pay attention
to to it in the first place but it
certainly confused what the thing
actually is you know it's a
computational knowledge engine that
answers questions by Computing things
it's not searching the web for a bunch
of places to link you to a different
objective
um so you know I think that caused some
confusion but I have to say that that
you know we uh often Alpha's use kind of
grew pretty rapidly
and was very kind of driven by word of
mouth and has continued to be that way
um and sort of this use case of things
like uh uh doing
um you know students doing solving math
chemistry whatever problems on it was
sort of a thing that developed very
organically I mean we we made this
effort I think it was in the fall of
2009
um we had this concept of what we call
Homework Day which was going to be a a
kind of uh you know see how to do your
homework on a machine type thing I have
to say in the end it was a poorly
conceived kind of concept
um and uh it wasn't clear
it was it was it was a bit muddled
um but it had some it had some kind of
nice material that got produced for it
um but uh that was that was kind of one
of the things but I didn't really have
any significant effect I mean I would
say when when wolfen Alpha was young and
there was some you know media thing that
came out about it you'd see that blip in
the traffic you'd see a blip after a
while after just a month or so so you
know the overall traffic could grow into
the point where you know a story in the
New York Times or whatever it was really
would barely register in the um in in
the actual traffic volumes that you
would see
all right let's see
um
gosh so many questions
um
oh my
uh
a lot of interesting questions here oh
my gosh okay
says I see many papers from the 1940s
even 1930s in uh physics journals that
are typeset very nicely how did they do
this without things like latex
oh my
they used uh put a typesetting machines
and there was uh so
question
back in very early days right in the in
the what 1400s or something people had
invented movable type which meant you
would have just individual letters A's
and B's and things in in cases you know
you would have the lower case of the
uncapital letters and the uppercase of
the capital letters and you would pick
out these letters just individual
Letters Out of lead and you would
assemble them in a little tray and then
you would print from that and when I was
a kid I I did some of that
um you know those those devices still
existed at that time
but by the 1930s or so 1940s maybe there
were photo type setting machines where
you would uh compose the um uh
where you would have some specification
language you have some way of typing in
um the specification of what was
supposed to be typeset and it was made
photographically and it was etched onto
a plate and then that plate was used for
printing
now when that happened people started
having to do math type setting as well
as just regular text and so on and so
there there started to be essentially
languages on these photo type setting
machines for specifying
um the uh how to represent math
and one of the things was was
interesting was the people who were
doing photo type setting they didn't
know math from anything they were just
like it looks like this you know I have
a manuscript that is you know whereas a
handwritten formula or maybe a typed on
a typewriter formula with a little bit
of handwritten stuff added in and I want
to make that something that I can put in
the photo type setting machine and so
they're all these names like I remember
one of them is uh things called fences
which are the names for absolute value
signs vertical bars
um I think are called fences in the um
in sort of photo type setting lingo and
there are these names that are very kind
of whimsical
appearance-based names for all these all
these constructs that are used in
mathematics but there started to be
languages for representing photo type
setting
um that included mathematical stuff that
was usually called penalty copy I think
because it was kind of like you would
type you know you're typing a newspaper
column or something and that was really
fast to type and you could enter it in
the photo type setting machine and it
would be well good but when it came to a
piece of math that was a big pain and it
would take lots of effort to kind of you
know move things around and so on so
there were languages oh gosh what were
their names
what were their names
um
there were languages used by specialist
photo type setting people uh kind of um
trades people who did photo type setting
that were used to to typeset mathematics
and that was a technology that existed
certainly
by 1930s and 1940s that absolutely
existed
um and uh I would think
well I mean there are books I mean I
have books from the 1600s that have some
mathematics in them and I would think
that was done by taking the pieces of
lead type and if you wanted to have a
superscript you would get a smaller
piece of lead type and you would stuff
another piece of lead in there to get
that superscript held in place
um on the on the page and yeah you
certainly see that that kind of thing in
you know I think that those were very I
mean in um uh that was one technology
then there were things like wood Cuts
where you would explicitly make kind of
carve things out that way I mean they're
uh uh certainly well in Newton's
principia 1687 there was quite a bit of
mathematical notation that was um uh in
the earlier books as well so I think
that was done by literally just taking
pieces of lead type and moving them
around I mean occasionally there were
exotic things that would happen where
you would have to actually make a new
piece of lead type there's a famous
story that Bertrand Russell when he was
doing the Whitehead Russell principia
Mathematica book in 1910 that was sort
of a an early mathematical logic uh
um impressive show-off piece of
mathematical logic I would say
um that um he had invented some new
symbolism and um he needed to get that
typeset and the Cambridge University
press was very you know no no we're not
going to do that et cetera et cetera et
cetera so Russell had somebody just make
the lead type and apparently uh so The
Story Goes uh you know Russell was to be
seen with a wheelbarrow kind of Wheeling
the type to the Press so that they could
type set pieces of the Mathematica book
in 1910.
so then what happened so there were
these specialist prototype setting
systems that were really used only by
the professional phototype Setters when
computers started to be able to do photo
type setting and really the early
versions of that were things like t-roth
the typesetting system in Unix that was
developed at Bell Labs
um by oh my gosh
um I think Brian Cunningham ended up
being part of that but I forget there
was a different person who was it was I
think the originator of that but tyroff
kind of imitated uh sort of some of that
early
um
uh some of those earlier sort of by hand
photo type setting things and t-roth's
Target device was a phototype setting
machine so I think it eventually had to
sort of plug in to it had to drive a
photo type setting machine using its
native language now into the middle of
all of this Don knuth developed Tech
because he wanted to type set his own
books and uh and then that um and has
this whole DVI mechanism which I guess
is a thing that sort of for
compatibility with phototype Setters and
then after all of that came the
PostScript language postcode page
description language
um which sort of was the the thing that
really launched the um the desktop
publishing uh Revolution with the you
know postcode being built into laser
writers and so on and that was that was
kind of how that developed but the
ability to do some kind of typesetting
math was certainly existed much much
earlier I mean when I was
uh you know first writing physics papers
in the 1970s
um you know I would type them on a
typewriter and I would hand write the
alphas and lambdas and things like that
and I would uh you know the things like
the bars and so on I would I would just
move the typewriter uh Cara you know
um uh roller so that you know you put
the bar in the right place and things
like this and it was sort of a mixture
of handwritten stuff and so on one of
the Innovations at that time was the IBM
selectric typewriter which had these
golf balls where you would have uh you
know you have the keyboard and the
keyboard would say you know at the
position of the W or something that
would correspond to uh you know put the
character that corresponds to that
location on this golf ball like thing
that was being turned around that would
specify what was actually printed based
on you typing a w so the typical thing
that you would do then was you would
have a golf ball that corresponds bonded
to let's say the Greek alphabet and you
would literally you know flip out you
know you would you would pull this
little lever you'd pull out the golf
ball that um was for the ordinary
English character set you put in the one
for the Greek character set then you
would type you know I think a q as a
gamma if I remember correctly
um and an a was an alpha and so on you
would type those things and and often as
a practical matter you would you would
type things but you would leave spaces
for the Greek letters and then you would
go back and go to the beginning of the
line again and put in a different golf
ball and type those characters and so on
and that was a technology when when um
let's see what my first papers for
example I would hand write the um that
was probably 1975-ish I would hand write
all the all the formulas uh you know
after I typed what I could type I would
hand write the Rest by um
uh by 1970
eight maybe even 77 yeah when I was
first in the US
um people had these IBM's electric
typewriters maybe that was an American
Film or maybe they didn't have that in
the UK I can't remember
um and everyone was doing this thing
about swapping out golf balls and things
I think I was uh most people would leave
it to the secretary to um uh you know to
type the papers I I tended to be uh uh
sometimes something of a
do-it-yourselfer
um even if um uh very fine um uh person
who would type papers some a woman named
Helen tuck who was the assistant who
actually did Fineman and Marigold man
and also to the theoretical physics
group in general at Caltech and I
remember one of my moments with um uh
there was I'd written this paper uh that
used actually computer
um
uh you know used a whole bunch of
computer calculations to calculate all
of these exotic formulas and things
and uh but but the the final paper I
sort of handwritten out a bunch of
formulas and I gave it to Helen and you
know she was going to type it and she
types the thing and uh you know comes
back and every time I had written a nine
she typed it as a g and I said why did
you do that so he said papers never have
Nines in them you know because nobody
had ever had computers to calculate all
these exotic formulas so the probability
of having you know actually the the way
numbers work with benford's law and so
on the chance at least that the initial
digits are ones is much higher than jots
the initial digit is a nine but you know
it was very rare for a paper to be full
of of formulas that had Nines in them so
so she typed them all as G's uh as a a
reasonable AI type inference that just
turned out to be wrong because the prior
was uh was wrong because I was using
computers to calculate uh formulas which
one hadn't seen before that time
let's see
um
well there are questions here
all right there's a question here about
perpetual motion machines
um Anon says it's been said that a real
perpetual motion machine cannot exist do
you agree or do you think we can get
there we just don't know how yet
you know it so happens that I've been
studying thermodynamics recently a
subject that I started studying 50 years
ago when I was like 12 years old or
something and um I finally am trying to
write down a a clear understanding
because it dovetails a lot of things
we've done in our physics project
looking at the structure of space-time
and quantum mechanics and things like
this
so just to give a little bit of History
so you know steam engines were a big
thing in the 1700s late 1700s and people
like James Watt and so on were were
um figuring out how do you make a more
efficient steam engine how do you take
Heat
in the steam engine and turn it into
mechanical work of turning Wheels around
to make a train go forward or to you
know move you know to pump water out of
my mind or something like this
so it was a great interest in how do you
go from heat to Mechanical work and how
efficient can you make that
and a lot of practical Innovations were
made in different you know newcomen
engines you know other people all these
different kinds of ways to um to make
efficient steam engines and turn
essentially the heat of steam that was
made by burning coal typically into
mechanical work
okay so then in the 1820s a chap called
Sadi Kano came along he was a kind of a
you come from the sort of military
political uh family in France that was
at sometimes in favor it's sometimes out
of favor but um he was he got interested
in the question of just how efficient
can you make a an engine a steam engine
a heat engine
um and so he tried to work that out and
he came up with a theory for that
um that was a sort of theoretical idea
of what a an idealized machine might be
like that was interesting and I still
need to read more of what he wrote
Because I think it was one of the first
places where the concept of an
abstracted machine really arose I mean
that comes in later in things like
turing machine there's an abstracted
machine for doing computation but this
was an abstracted machine for turning
heat into mechanical work
and he concluded things about the
efficiency of that and the idea that you
always had to have a hot pot and a cold
part and that sort of you got you got
the mechanical work by sort of the
interplay of the hot part and the cold
part
well
uh Kano at the time there was a question
of what is heat
and people didn't know what heat was
they thought it was a substance called
flogiston that was a fluid-like thing
that would sort of suffuse substances
and you could like have heat as a
disembodied kind of kind of material
now actually people even in the 1600s
had uh sort of thought that gases might
be atoms you know discrete things
bouncing around
um they had uh well Newton had had
particular ideas about that but they
were very gravity based and and people
sort of thought that for example in a
gas the reason that there was pressure
of a gas had to do with the fact that
the molecules if there were molecules
were repelling each other and through
some force a bit like gravity in truth
it is not repulsion it's just these
molecules are bouncing around and
colliding off each other and it's just
the mere momentum of those molecules
hitting the walls that causes pressure
but at the time it was very much thought
to be you know if it was molecules it
was molecules with repulsive forces in
them
so but by the early 1800s the sort of
flogist on idea of the substance that is
like heat that represents heat was
definitely in the ascendant and Kano was
very much in that tradition but
nevertheless he worked out these things
about the efficiency of heat engines and
so on and and wrote this book called on
the Motive Power of heat
um that talked about these kinds of
things and and uh gave some formulas and
so on
his work was somewhat lost
but then there started to be other
people who were interested in
um
uh sort of the relationship between heat
and mechanical work and so on and and
there's questions still kicked around
what was heat important experiment was
done by um James Prescott Jewell who um
uh noticed that when you sort of ground
a a cannon or something that the the
friction was going to generate heat the
mechanical work turned into heat
and and people were sort of noticing
that there was sort of this question of
was heat a form of energy what was
energy and was it interconvertible in
some way with energy and people were
very confused because well what became
clear by about 1850 by the 1850s was
that heat could be thought of as a type
of energy and that there was a notion of
interconvertibility of heat energy with
mechanical energy and that there was
this this one kind of thing called and
that you could call energy that was a
conserved quantity Where the total
amount of energy was conserved but it
could be in these different forms and
that turned into the first law of
thermodynamics
formulated around 1860-ish
that said heat is a form of energy and
you can kind of you can kind of count
energy from kinetic energy from
mechanical energy from from uh heat
energy and these are all sort of the
total amount of energy is conserved you
can set it up that way okay so then the
big question was well why you know in
principle heat and mechanical work were
both energy why couldn't you go from
heat energy to Mechanical work energy
and just get sort of why wasn't it easy
to go from heat to Mechanical work that
you had to have these things like you
had to have a hot pot and a cold part
and it was the flow of heat from one to
the other little generate mechanical
work you couldn't just go from a lump of
heat to Mechanical work
and people really wanted to do that they
want to just take heat and make
mechanical work
so one thing that happened and then what
what came out was the second law of
Thermodynamics which essentially said
that there it wasn't possible to go you
could go from mechanical work to heat
but you couldn't go just back directly
from uh from heat to Mechanical work you
couldn't you couldn't do that so what
arose was this idea of Perpetual Motion
machines Perpetual mushroom machine the
first kind and perpetual motion machine
the second kind a perpetual motion
machine of of the first kind is one that
gets energy from nothing
the just that breaks the law of
conservation and energy and just
generates energy when there wasn't any
energy there before a perpetual motion
machine of the second kind is one which
breaks the second law of Thermodynamics
and goes back from the energy in the
form of heat to energy of the form of
mechanical work when the second law says
you can go from one to the other but not
not back so to speak
so what happened the perpetual motion
machine the second kind people have been
claiming you could make them forever and
ever and ever
um what does it really what's really
involved well the problem is that in
we now know that heat is a kind of
motion it's the microscopic motion of
molecules and so on
um and the the fact that we sort of
don't naturally go back from heat to
Mechanical work as the heat is all
randomized and you'd have to line all
those molecules up and get them all to
go sort of in the same direction which
is what you can do if you have a hot a
reservoir and a cold Reservoir they sort
of all flow from one to the other
um and and that's what
um uh and you need that some sort of
organizing print organizing structure to
sort of line up all that Randomness that
represents heat so by the way the second
law of Thermodynamics was stated in
various ways but one way of stating it
is heat doesn't spontaneously flow from
a colder body to a hotter body uh you
you get you know you a hotter thing can
make a colder thing hotter but not the
other way around that's one statement
another statement is basically that
perpetual motion machines are the second
kind don't exist that it's not possible
to just go take a lump of heat and
generate mechanical work from it okay so
what's really involved in this this is a
subtle thing I've been writing about it
recently hopefully I'll get this
finished in the next not too very long
um but uh this question of you know
you've got heat you've got this random
motions well are they really random what
do we mean by random they came from some
you know from some initial condition
maybe a very organized initial condition
but by virtue of some process they're
all randomized that process is a is what
I view as a computational process it's a
computationally irreducible process it's
a process where you're running this
computation and much like things like my
rule 30 cellular automaton for example
where you just have a simple rule and
from that simple rule just starting off
from let's say one black cell you make
this very complicated pattern that's
what's happening in thermodynamic
Behavior that's what's happening when
systematic mechanical work grind finding
the Canon you know Barrel or something
turns into pure heat of kind of
randomized
um uh randomized elements
um
and I think uh that this idea that what
you get is randomized is
um is a you know what exactly do we mean
by randomized it's randomized with
respect to the ways that we look at the
motion of molecules but it may not be
truly it's not truly randomized because
you can get it in a very definite way
with definite rules
so actually back in the 1860s when the
second order the Dynamics was first
coming into existence James Clerk
Maxwell I think I've talked about him
before I'm very impressed with him and
as I will learn more about him I I just
would really have liked to have met him
uh but you know he died a solid um uh
what was it 80 years before I was born
something like that
um the uh
so but in the case James Clark Maxwell
um in his book on the theory of heat for
example
um uh has a very nice description of
what he calls a Maxwell's demon that is
a microscopic
critter
that breaks the second war of
thermodynamics it's a little critter
that has a you know has a a a wall with
a door in it for example and the Critter
opens the door when there's a fast going
molecule and doesn't when there's a slow
going molecule whatever and basically is
able to sort the molecules just by being
down there at the molecular scale and
sort of uh uh analyzing what's going on
and so if you could have a Maxwell's
demon you would break the second order
of thermodynamics if you could have a
Maxwell's demon you would be able to uh
you know go in and sort the molecules
and you would be able to take that
randomized energy that is heat and your
demon could de-randomize that that uh
that energy
now does that work
well people have been arguing about that
for a long time and they've had all
kinds of different reasons why the demon
doesn't work oh the demon users needs to
use a flashlight to look at the
molecules and the flashlight will take
energy oh the demon needs to have a
memory and by erasing data in its memory
it necessarily has to expend uh generate
Heat
variety of different kinds of of things
I think what's true is uh that oh by the
way I should say people continue to
propose Maxwell's demon-like devices
even in the last few weeks there are
papers in sort of top physics journals
talking about these kinds of things most
of the time these days they're
electronic devices where you have
effectively noise that's coming in and
you have an electronic signal processor
that's cleaning up that noise to make
something systematic
um by the way like my friend dick
Feynman had a version of this with a
ratchet and Paul where where you would
say the random noise would make a
ratchet that always went in One
Direction and so even though there's
random noise you would be systematically
turning this wheel in One Direction
um and uh in fact Max Planck had had a
version of the secular of thermodynamics
which said it can't be that the sole
result of heat is to move some weight up
and down so to speak
um so uh
that had been um uh so so dick fireman
had a version of this and he said oh it
doesn't work because eventually the
ratchet and Paul heat up and they stop
working and so on
but I think what's really true about
this is it depends what you assume about
the the construction of the Maxwell's
demon if you assume the Maxwell demon
can be made of anything
then well you can make it work you can
have some system that's made of
electronics and so on and it's
interacting with gas molecules and it
can rectify the signal and sort of
de-randomize the gas molecules
now uh you know and if but on the other
hand if you say Maxwell's demon is sort
of made of the same stuff as the system
you're looking at then it's a different
story and then essentially it's a story
of computational irreducibility that you
can't sort of uh detect you can't jump
over the randomness to figure out what's
going to happen the way you make a
winning Maxwell's demon is you make
something that can uh that can kind of
predict what the gas molecules are going
to do before they do it be ready for it
and then sort of Leverage that
prediction
by the uh and and for that from that you
could make a perpetual motion machine
for the second kind if you could do that
the problem is that in practice there's
computational irreducibility and so you
can't make those kinds of predictions
with a computational device or in
particular with a computational device
that interfaces to sort of observers
like us you can't make such a thing now
actually what was it a couple years ago
now uh just for fun I was I was thinking
about this in the context of space-time
where in our models of space as a giant
Network one has very much the same kind
of thing going on as happens with
molecules and a gas you know the
structure of space as we perceive it is
made from these microscopic networks in
much the same way that the sort of
structure of a fluid or a gas is made
from microscopic motions of molecules
and so that raises the question of is
there a sort of Maxwell's demon for
space-time and if so what does it do
and what realizes well yes there is and
the analog of a Maxwell's demon for
space time is the ability to go faster
than the speed of light
um because in the um uh in the whole
structure of space-time this sort of
randomized jumping around is what makes
space have the kind of structure that we
experience it to have and that makes uh
sort of a flash of light that goes off
here will expand in in space-time in a
cone in a light cone and that light cone
will will sort of extend to a certain
point and that maximum extent
corresponds to the speed of light but
the truth is if you look down at the
level of the actual microscopic you know
structure of the network you would see
all sorts of little proboscisors coming
out of that light cone all sorts of
little places where you've got a little
bit faster than the light cone not
actually because anything's going sort
of microscopically in the network
fastens speed of light but because the
structure of space is a complicated
thing and it's construction let me give
you an analogy in in this room there's a
bunch of molecules most air molecules go
only a millionth of a meter before they
hit another air molecule and so their
directions are continually randomized so
if I were to release some gas right here
it would take a long time for you know
many minutes let's say for that gas to
diffuse the other side of the room
because those gas molecules even though
microscopically they're going at roughly
the speed of sound they keep on hitting
other gas molecules their directions are
randomized they follow this random walk
the aggregate speed at which they go is
quite slow
but if you could only pick the right
molecule if you could only you know bet
on the right molecular horse and every
time there's a collision you say I want
to go on that one I want to go on that
one I want to go on that one well then
you would have a chance to just go at
the speed of sound because you would be
kind of moving oh that one's going in
the right direction okay now that one's
going in the right direction you're not
dealing with this random walk of going
in all kinds of different directions
you're always just picking the right
molecule to go on and going at the speed
of sound so what would happen is you
know this question of how fast can you
get can you go as a gas molecule for
example across this room the answer is
well actually you can go a lot faster
than uh than the standard speed of
diffusion you can go actually at the
speed of sound and so something similar
happens in space-time I think that you
could if you could surf the right atoms
of space you would be able to go at a
speed greater than the local speed of
light but in fact it's a problem them
very much like the the problem of making
a perpetual motion machine of the second
kind that you can't you know you can't
do the computation let alone having sort
of the fingers small enough to reach
down to the atoms of space a tough thing
to do given that everything we have is
made of of atoms of space but you know
you can't do that
um uh just from a pure computational
point of view you can't figure out which
atom of space to bet on so to speak to
go to the next place so I think the
impossibility of Perpetual Motion
Machines of the second kind is is really
a computational statement more than it
is anything else and I think that uh you
know it's it's worth remembering that if
we existed down at the scale of
molecules there are all kinds of motions
that we might care about that may be
happening May easily be happening in
lots of different situations
but the Motions that we care most about
are these very large-scale motions that
we call mechanical work and that's
because we're big compared to molecules
and so the things we care about are
things big compared to molecules we
might have some it could be the case
that somewhere in our biology there is
you know somewhere in the kidneys or
something or in the lungs there is some
detailed structure that actually doesn't
care about the aggregate mechanical work
of the gas but cares about some little
tiny Eddy in the gas that works this way
or that and that that interacts with
some very microscopic you know Micron
sized uh feature of um of of sort of the
the the the um the pieces of the you
know the end leaves of the lung of the
tree of of tubes in our lungs and so on
so you know there are there are things
like that that could happen where what
counts as mechanical work
might be a little different to a
different kind of Observer of the Ghasts
and it might be the case that just those
little swirls that we at the level of
what has been talked about in
thermodynamics to date don't care about
but as a as a sort of the last step and
you know diffusion in the lung or
something we might care about it and and
it might be important and actually
because of the development of
thermodynamics to date we really
wouldn't know about it yet because that
hasn't been a thing that's really been
looked at
so okay so someone's commenting here
Dr Mike here is commenting at a Quantum
scale there seems to be perpetual motion
um
uh and okay let's talk about that for
just a second here we should wrap up
soon but um uh okay
um
well
oh boy this is the kind of worms
so
uh
Mickey Mike whatever is certainly right
that
um
okay
how does this work in in um at the
quantum scale
nothing
is ever
completely motionless there's always
something we don't call it heat
we call it vacuum fluctuations
now let me fill in a few things so the
third law of thermodynamics
says you can't get to absolute zero you
can't make things you can't get rid of
all heat in a finite number of steps and
essentially the reason for the third law
is this that heat is all this random
motion to get rid of the heat you have
to get rid of all that random motion you
have to kind of have something that
blocks this random piece that random
piece that random piece
and that's a a
because of computational irreducibility
that's ultimately not a thing that you
can finitely do you can't sort of block
all those different computationally
irreducible pieces but the third law is
the story of what it takes to get down
to absolute zero where things where
there is no heat there's no ordinary
classical Heat
okay in quantum mechanics and in Quantum
field theory in particular there is
always a zero point fluctuation and and
roughly the reason for that you can see
it in many different ways but um sort of
a traditional quantum mechanical way of
seeing it is there's this uncertainty
principle in quantum mechanics that says
you can't for example simultaneously
measure a position and momentum energy
and time you can't simultaneously
measure uh well you basically can't
can't guarantee that there are zero
particles in this measurement
then as there's an uncertainty and
particle number as there is in all these
other quantum mechanical kinds of things
and what another way to think of that
what's happening is that in there's no
way to just turn off Quantum field
Theory you're always making particle
anti-particle pairs they pop up and they
and they annihilate again it might take
10 to the minus 20 seconds they pop up
they annihilate and so on and in that's
always happening and so what we say oh
it's the vacuum nothing's happening
there you can't switch off the quantum
field Theory so there are always these
little things that are going on these
little fluctuations that are going on
and so when we perceive things to happen
in physics it was always relative to
that vacuum fluctuating vacuum so to
speak so we're saying what happened in
addition to all those action
fluctuations that were going on but in
the pure vacuum there is this sort of
continual kind of uh production of
particle anti-particle powers and so on
and and there are some effects where you
can see that there's one called the
Casimir effect uh where it works this
way you have two plates two metal plates
they're just sitting on the vacuum and
they feel a small force of attraction
between them why is that the reason is
that in this Quantum field there are all
these different things that can happen
these particle antiparticle pairs that
can be produced
the the presence of those metal plates
restricts the kinds of particle
antiparticle pairs that can be produced
between the metal plates but not the
ones that can be produced outside the
metal plates essentially ones that are
too low in energy where energy is is a
energy and distance have an uncertainty
relation and so on and if you have too
low in energy you are too delocalized uh
in space and you sort of can't fit that
mode of the particles in between these
plates and so those vacuum fluctuations
those very low frequency long wavelength
vacuum fluctuations can't happen between
the plates but they can happen outside
the plates and so there's a small force
of the of the vacuum so to speak outside
the plates there's more vacuum in some
sense outside the plates and inside so
there's a force that pushes them
together now that explanation is a bit
of a put up job because in detail it
isn't in fact the case that every
if you have different shapes of boxes
and things and you have like a cuboid of
uh of material turns out vacuum
fluctuations don't actually quite work
that way when you work them out with the
actual Quantum field Theory and they
have sometimes repulsive forces rather
than attractive forces and so on
actually back in 1981 I wrote a little
paper with a chap called the an ambion
about we call it properties of the
vacuum and we talked about exactly this
phenomenon of if you have different
shaped boxes you know kind of what
forces are there from the vacuum and
actually interestingly enough
um we worked out what was sort of what
happens if you go with shape a box to
that shaper box and so on and and you
know noticed a few things about it few
years go by a letter from a chap called
Robert forward who was a physicist and
science fiction writer actually he says
are you sure your calculations are right
yeah I'm pretty sure they're right says
well if your calculations are right
there is a closed cycle like the Kano
cycle that uh for heat engines there's a
closed cycle that extracts energy from
the vacuum
and and so
and looked at this and he's right that
you know the Casimir effect this this
vacuum fluctuation effect you can
squidge the Box this shape and that
shape and you can make this closed cycle
and you can be just you know mining
energy out of the vacuum how can this
possibly be how can it possibly work
well the one feature of that is that
idea even if it didn't make it into
science fact definitely made it into
science fiction and I really am amused I
had a bunch of movies which where people
are like we're going to blow it up with
we're going to drive the spaceship with
zero point fluctuations we're going to
you know have a thing that that is a
kind of a blow everything up with zero
point fluctuations and so on uh which I
think came from that
um uh you know that investigation uh in
in reality it doesn't quite work because
in order what are you going to make the
box out of you make have to make the box
out of a material that is essentially
completely impermeable to Quantum fields
and you just can't do that if you make a
metal box well a metal box has you know
electrons and it has a crystal lattice
and it it restricts certain uh uh sort
of electromagnetic fields but it can't
Shield all electromagnetic fields
because it's made of things of a certain
size and so on so in the end you can't
do this with standard material things
now I have to say I was just recently
looking at and actually as I talk to you
guys I have an idea
um I was just recently looking at the
thermodynamics of space-time which has
been studied a bit in the case of black
holes but not so much outside of black
holes and you give me the idea that I
wonder whether that kind of closed
thermodynamic cycle actually works in
space-time and whether there is a
similar kind of phenomenon now I I
should say that in our models of physics
the whole idea of vacuum fluctuations uh
is is very much tied into the very
structure of space itself these things
where you have sort of this Quantum
process that's happening that is the the
rewriting of the structure of space it's
something that's sort of below the level
of quantum gravity even you're you're
seeing the structure of spaces knitted
together from all these things that you
might describe as vacuum fluctuations
all these different kinds of microscopic
processes and so so you would expect and
actually it's a good exercise okay my my
homework exercise is to figure out
whether you can make a uh uh a machine
that will be a perpetual motion machine
of the second kind operating on
space-time uh my guess actually is that
you probably can do it
um but that it probably leverages the um
it probably is based on the expansion of
the universe and it probably is
essentially uh sort of what you're doing
is in the end taking energy out of the
expansion of the universe that you that
you're basically taking what would
otherwise be an overall flow of
expansion of the universe and you're
saying no no I don't want to use that to
just make the universe bigger I'm going
to use that locally to you know power my
car or whatever uh not that not that I
think that's likely to be practical
anytime soon
um but anyway so so
the um the story of uh
um
uh there are you know there are vacuum
fluctuations and um
um
the extent to which
uh well which which are kind of like an
irreducible form of heat
that exists in a sense heat of that kind
is what knits together the structure of
space-time and what is underneath
everything that we see in the universe
um
okay there's one last question here
relating to this topic uh
um
there's a comment about something I've
never heard of the Oxford clock I don't
know what that is
um
it's a comment here from Aaron a
question if remember what were people's
reactions to kano's exploration of steam
engine mechanics and the development of
the Econo cycle I think people ignored
it I think people didn't understand the
points they ignored it
um
you know I think uh Kano died quite
young and um he was
uh you know I think his father had been
quite a a significant sort of military
political figure in the Napoleonic
period And I think that um uh the um
um um
uh you know has happened to quite a few
it happens throughout history that you
know people's work is enmeshed with the
sort of local politics of the time and
uh uh you know I uh
Kano didn't
uh uh have the problem that uh avarice
galwa had in 1830 something uh every
skull War had been this sort of
precocious math person who invented kind
of group Theory ideas and is about 20
years old or something but was also a
young hot shot political hot political
activist and um anyway eventually died
in a duel which was sort of a put up job
that was connected to his whole
political activism story
um and I think Kano was not himself in
that in that mold but around the same
time but I think he sort of had family
things there and I think that didn't
help his um uh the longevity of his
ideas at the time unfortunately and
subsequently been people like William
Thompson Lord Kelvin picked them up in
the 1860s and Beyond
um they were you know what he did was
sort of rediscovered but people were
thinking about it separately I mean it's
sort of an interesting Twist of history
that um uh Kelvin
um talked a lot about about the
technical thermodynamics and the
impossibility of Perpetual Motion
machines
and um and then you know then we get to
1900 ish and people are asking him well
what about flying machines what about
heavier than air flight
and I think he was probably thinking and
I need to track down this history more
carefully I think he was probably
thinking about his proofs of the
impossibility of Perpetual Motion
machines because he said heavily heavier
than air flight is just not going to be
possible it's going to be sort of
impossible probably he thought for the
same generalized types of reasons that
turning heat into mechanical work wasn't
going to be possible so it was sort of
an interesting mistake that came out of
his work in the second war of
thermodynamics and I really need to
track down more details about um how
that worked
uh and um oh Aaron asks a question that
I don't know the answer to the history
of uh the Fahrenheit scale and ancient
representations of temperature
um and non-numerical ones you know the
idea of temperature as a a definite
thing which is essentially the content
of the zeroth law of thermodynamics the
zeroth law of thermodynamics kind of
says there is this notion of equilibrium
and there's this one number that
characterizes sort of the the that
characterizes equilibrium and it's just
temperature the idea that there is a
notion of temperature is an idea that
must have
hmm when did that come into existence uh
you know thermometers were a thing of I
think the 1700s don't think they existed
before that time and people were using
you know alcohol thermometers later
mercury thermometers using the expansion
of materials as they got hotter because
you know the reason they expand is
because the atoms are bouncing around
more and they have an easier time
spending more time further away from
each other so that's why materials tend
to get bigger when they get hotter but
that's what you do in a alcohol
thermometer or mercury thermometer
you're you're seeing how this column of
fluid gets expands as you heat the thing
up the Fahrenheit scale was derived from
um uh you know it's like like let's be
useful let's have it go from the lowest
temperature recorded in this particular
city in Germany to the highest
temperature recorded in the city in
Germany and have that go zero to a
hundred
um and so uh you know it is it is
convenient in the sense that typical
sort of places in uh sort of the the
heavily populated latitudes are um uh
well I guess they're other heavily
populated latitudes but the
traditionally heavily populated
latitudes
um you know sort of go from roughly zero
to 100 in the Fahrenheit scale
um but uh
that's something that um is uh
um you know I think I think so I think
thermometers once thermometers come in
people wanted to have these scales of
temperature that told you sort of uh you
know gave you gave you a sense of how
hot something was now the absolute scale
of temperature people like Kelvin uh
after whom the the absolute scale of
temperature in kelvins is is named you
know realized that there was an actual
minimum there was an actual zero that
you know once you knew that temperature
was a form of of of motion was the
result of motion of molecules you knew
that there was going to be a zero of
temperature a true absolute zero of
temperature that corresponded to the
Motions not the molecules not moving
around and that's minus two seven three
point one six degrees Centigrade zero
kelvins now you know there are many
tricky things about temperature I'll
just I'll just zoom to a couple of weeks
ago uh you know in wolfen Alpha and in
Northern language we have a
representation of temperature and
um we what's tricky is temperature
differences are not the same as absolute
temperatures and you can end up with a
temperature difference of some number of
degrees centigrade and that temperature
difference you can multiply it by things
you can do all kinds of things with it
it's a temperature difference
the the absolute temperature of such a
such 100 degrees the word degrees is put
in there to indicate that it's this kind
of scale
um that that's a different kind of thing
than a temperature difference you can't
really multiply if you take 100 degrees
centigrade and you multiply it by three
that's kind of a meaningless thing to do
because the zero isn't you know that
that thing is just a you know the
difference of temperature 50 to 100
degrees Centigrade that's perfectly
meaningful the difference of 50 degrees
Centigrade it's perfectly meaningful
thing you can multiply and so on but you
can't multiply the the the temperature
you can in kelvins because they are on
this absolute scale you can do this
multiplication but you can't for degrees
Centigrade so one of the questions is in
the notation that people have when they
write 50 degrees Centigrade it's like
how do you know whether that's one of
these multipliable things that's a
temperature difference whether it's just
the temperature of 50 degrees Centigrade
made on the degrees scale so to speak
and and so once needed an annotation for
this and there just isn't one so we
invented one and it's a little thing
with a capital Delta that that's kind of
goes down downstairs with the degree
Stein upstairs uh there's some people
have used sort of put the degree sign
off to the c or whatever but that's
really obscure looking and then not
understandable so we're inventing we'll
be introducing this actually in version
13 2 of wolfen language we'll be
introducing this notation for
temperature differences of of degree
difference degrees Centigrade it's kind
of it's kind of amazing that you know
that that hasn't been a thing so far but
but now that we're trying to make all
these Notions of temperature and so on
more computable we do have to have it be
a thing
um I am wondering whether uh you know in
in ancient times whether people had a
notion well they obviously had a notion
it's hot today it's cold tomorrow I know
for example the Babylonians for 700
years recorded these astronomical
diaries that recorded sort of facts
about what was going on they recorded
positions of planets they recorded rain
they recorded the level of the river
things they recorded corn prices grain
prices things like that
um but they didn't record temperature
so I I don't think they had a notion of
um they didn't for whatever reason that
wasn't a a quantity that perhaps they
had no way to say it was a hot day today
it was a cold day to today maybe in
maybe in the position of uh of of uh of
ancient Babylon
I don't know I don't know the
temperatures profiles of that part of
the world at that time in history maybe
didn't change much I'm not sure it
certainly rained a bunch I everyone
knows that from the astronomical Diaries
um but uh so you know I think this some
oh actually
I'm I'm I'm I'm thinking to myself I'm
realizing something that I've missed
here there is the central England
temperature record which I believe goes
to 1650. so I think that that must have
been the time when the first
thermometers were around that's the
longest running kind of record when
people say you know are things getting
warmer in the world or not you can look
at the central England temperature uh
series and that gives you for one place
obviously the environment has changed it
probably might be getting warmer in a
city because it's full of uh you know
asphalt and so on and the and the you
know absorbing the sun better it might
have been you know who knows what was
happening there that that um that might
have changed the temperature but but
that's I think it goes to 1650 that
particular record so that that probably
gives one that's probably the longest um
that probably goes on a sense of when
thermometers were starting to come in
but but at that time obviously people
started caring about recording
temperatures but I don't think I don't
think it was a thing in Antiquity I
don't think people noticed that I mean
they they well certainly there are
certainly words for hot and cold for
sure
um and uh people
must have known okay so here's another
Point
um in
uh
in developing sort of the refining of of
metals
um people like Agricola for example uh
you know who wrote about kind of the um
uh turning getting Metals out of ore
they certainly knew had to heat it up
and you had to get it to a certain
point I wonder at what point the word
temperature came in because they they
must have known that you have to put a
lot of fire underneath this thing to
melt it to get this or that to happen
so I you know there must have been a
notion of that I just don't know uh I
don't know how it was characterized I
wonder whether the Alchemists
um had a notion of temperature
I'm I'm not immediately remembering
um a notion of temperature that those
guys talked about so it's an interesting
question I I don't know the um I I don't
know and I don't know whether Alchemists
had a um
uh you know they they might have had a
notion of you know
um
you know the temperature at which
Quicksilver Mercury freezes or you know
the temperature at which water boils
they might have had a notion of that and
that would mean that they would have had
a word for temperature and so on
um I don't even know the etymology of
the word temperature so okay you guys
have hit a uh a vein of lack of
knowledge on my part that they should
have and I'm going to look it up
um so thank you for um thank you for
raising that all right we've we've gone
much longer than I expected but thanks
for those interesting questions I see a
lot more that I'll be looking forward to
um to trying to address some when we do
another one of these probably in about
two weeks
so um thanks very much for joining me
and uh see you another time bye for now